im nordrhein-westfälischen wuppertal
werden bei der firma grünke diese
aufsteller als spuck schutz geformt in
corona zeiten heiß begehrt doch vor
wenigen tagen bekommt der
familienbetrieb post eine firma
verbietet alexander grünke jetzt seinen
spuck spuk schutz zu nehmen und fordert
16.250 euro
ich bin aus allen wolken gefallen
unseren marken recht alt ist immer sehr
teuer und ja da konnte ich erst mal
nicht schlafen also das hat mich doch
ich mitgenommen
seit jahren produziert grünke die
aussteller aus acryl sie schützen
lebensmittel oder in geschäften das
gegenüber im internet bezeichnet die
firma ihre aufsteller mit dem
gebräuchlichen begriff spuck schutz
dafür wird sie jetzt plötzlich abgemahnt
der grund eine firma aus österreich hat
sich den begriff spuck schutz bei der eu
als marke eintragen lassen unglaublich
wer das wort gewerblich verwendet
braucht plötzlich eine genehmigung wir
sehen das nicht als marke sondern als
beschreiben den begriff also für das
ding selbst so wie ich gesagt habe wie
die kaffeemaschine da gibt es
verschiedene hersteller
die nennen das aber alle kaffeemaschinen
das wäre genauso als würde ich mir die
kaffeemaschine schützen lassen nun alle
die eine kaffeemaschine vertreibe
verklagen
das kann doch nicht sein aber warum
schützt eine eu-behörde das wort spuck
schutz
das zuständige amt für geistiges
eigentum mit sitzen im spanischen
alicante erklärt nur lapidar wir
kommentieren niemals einzelfälle
die abmahnende firma wiederum sieht sich
völlig im recht der anwalt teilt uns mit
unserer mandantschaft ist zu
abwehrmaßnahmen benötigt um den bestand
der marke zu sichern für grünke geht es
um sein geschäft seine kunden etwa die
ärztin sabine mura können das alles
nicht glauben
ein spuk schutz ist für mich eine
beschreibung dieses gegenstandes hier
und ist für mich kein markenname das ist
dann doch menschen gibt die halt aus
dieser krise noch gewinn gewinn im sinne
von monetären gewinn schöpfen wollen das
finde ich ziemlich erschüttern alexander
grün ist kein einzelfall viele andere
firmen wurden ebenfalls abgemahnt am
ende wird wohl ein gericht entscheiden
müssen ob in deutschland einen spuck
spuk schutz heißen darf